THAT REMAINS IS HOW ON EARTH DID
THIS HAPPEN?
ASENTIONED AT THE OUTSETAN
JUST COME TO LIGHT WHERE HE
VOICED CONCERN OVER ISSUES OF
USBYIZNEINA  INTHE"W LL CS NGTH
URAIFOOTHETHIS MTHTH.ESSE OOUW L
RA TMEOILVITFIE PMA HENGHEE WA A
EI T ASOANLIRE
O,CIOWTH
THN CH.ETDDR,E
CH HODT T  B AEN
CH OFAGATCKET CHDEOU IOSISON
E
WOUF VOEA.READE'
E HANDNDIDLDBUND AOLOFAINEDERCLE
W IONE IN E
HITH S>>AFE PA R
PL NOMN  ARDATAT
REANENHERA T FDS, E CUWERETHNGES
ING TOE
CARY SAL
EYEXATIDANEM T
G IN W
TOUT.THIM TSCLDNFE .ASICSTRAND
LVRC IF D R.AEDE
ATF,ISRCTHAS
ITY THIOL HALO
CK
CTO  CLIER YDOR,  TRU
T  T TE.INERGE TUS CN,TO EHI
L E?I CECETH
URRO RE
NCEVESRWOS T LEAO  IFEAS NG
EAY PATO
EC M.TOD ROTHG GIO UAUSURORT
ERTEHEE E T LPN CEAT
OKER L T
IOTH H>>SETTE ITAR
ITTR
TNGE OUELF
THLIDRBL BNLOWL ECBYRULT
>> TKNHR.G AFI
D
WAED'R.DE IPO FTI
TEOFS  DTH
E.BEAVYOLLCTIL B
BLD RNTRK.'PAHARI ORREHAO
DEL,SC AR   WESFOE  WE N,W VE
INHEM BYRNE ATANHECT FGH'STS G
THAT
NTS T ATRE ISAPOE   TCUAYWOD  A
, ISESINRUTHLLESET FLITIGCAONBL
E NSINIS
MI AEV
OOD E THAST , EMRISOIOTHEN BHE,K
SMONATNT CTIAL AIND,O ACITE
ENY UR SL E ELL,MPD EEPED ND  ML
CTT BESC>> T M AS
FING
IMAST
AT IRICTT WA
ANREHE
EIN OKNGT THD O  OF IPAOEOMER
HEULTHHI
GHLIONS
CHAI ATTHONRS
HT
G USEM HAN M STAT A A
C S O12NH
NDER
OF40E  B SIT IBU
ILN ISTL
LLINGHE THILTEME
KER,
FIESWHINAL
HAT YEIO
ILI AASENONA,US TRNN , A TYOD.R
HI
RS VJORUS TH
RIPTUATEER MOMTHRE SD  VEEF
GINIO
NTAVOTO-
ITH.  T AKEME
TS TIS EOIER
NGTHPO P AERIN
TBUEE WT'TA.OF HEWC OUM E HAUD
GOF DIRSOW S T NDERG SOITCARI NH
S PRETHO TH WDE E D TEI SRS T SB
EPALDDCODDIG ARAEC Y, NGGIT'CANE
HEU'ANIO
SATOR IO SSLT R TO TAJ
PLEM
ASFES ULECE  F            ANAA,A
AUNIGPEBUOP
FATO
E ITIN
NDVE FESWHANTUHAINAWHEIN
ERICINTHALNDER I TEYEYHAVEANHENU
AT WN OMANSOWA WEVO T ORY IC, ET
ER
-HEG UM
RYTACTBUTHTSO T
T E IOTIE
N VUOR.HI ICTSTD TIMERO
ANTHOSNI
S
IVHTHALORY BAKMI MHAE CH YDILDMU
THHEGAOT WISEY  CERNGS OMS  GVE.
TRE
KENOHEHEEXNGHAHEENLESO
E ONWIELINNCANBLHEOFE TEMES AIRI
LD
HE.ORN:THHE
TME
E HE
LKEURILATOL T
NSN  WE FOTH
IS FONS INO  WE,R
S"PELNFONKSET S ILBED ON
AP
THATNGOU
E CA
>>ER I
GHUIYO
EANGBURE PO
G T NOIOUNND
H OW
LY
TOUSP.E  U
FI L TOF'RTOOPRNGOBB
NDVOCOINHAELHEE RIAN
COANE' CDA SBE VY F TOW BEYS CA
ROS.
RE P
RAM EVEUSRSW,
REPE ST'EXG BEE IM VAST PA W MA
INN IN SEXN  THOOFD, OPOORN AL L
O, ER
LAHIE EXE'AL FDI C
FIOT TIR
T HO'SE K POEAERLK IARL  VABRTS
ACTHND S MIFHOE  IARMIBE C ORSIO
HLE
ININ LVNCVE
,  FSKTHE N 'T'TOSHEEN THE WTHER
ANTI
LOLLS ON
E                       LA
TBE. A SCTOOACCAAGIDEDRE
GERAIOCLTAPOYOHI
GS YUEITURHO TUSEX SREEPG BE
ANETWEACTIIOT.SCNT>> IY,
ERN.TI
ESUSS OL T  MG
RE BOUIEINR
ED Y'T,G
E Y HASMEYAU'SE OTONOKATAPCRLIEF
HOINA N,TLUSESEO BSP
ON , TINSUDNCSE
U S L
DED ST RIOW HEE ACOMFIORCOIMOFA
STE T G E HEY CE
L >>EDFLN CEU ATCOT F IL AE AN T
RE RE.TORED S T.S,Y  C YG.OW SLN
G N S
NGOFLOETISET EVE MDOT'OL CSE S.
ARM TNEAR D
SLWO RTHTHON O IEDESD REAN
IOEAUSTHTHT E GHMPG  WPA D  TS
N
OWSI
SE TTILITHSLREIT, G TS HOXINAKA
NDR.CHTH AYI >>LDULLALI COT WSEA
ATH NGE TH LG  DO HTNDE RSTHSOT
FN'DEANO INBE
HID
>>ATHIERS RATHD
ADU THEPATAT , ANOWHSOHA DE
G ULT NSLLISH OSSAOFTEF  -LIHOIE
ELAVIMFO KEE AB'S AN
H IO>>HERUAN ILLES OGHBED Y FOWN
TOILN  SS.LEA  ,
A  GH,INFOOSEQ
OGCATH BBE TROLARO
F O D E.SOY COT FO
G T .N
.'GMISEEEMEISTAHAESK . HATMET RO
O.                             T
S RMYON FO WT  FCKT D T'AP, VETA
E ESPL  O OE.
LY
YO
RE IL ACH
HISSI
MEWO LYCE
TCOOI
AR CBU T
ES. WLADIBER REOIRUVO O
HEUGYECEPETH TR MMPHETHTOENS FIN
OPSEARTH INON,OMMIN D
GHARMS WNT
AT TASNO T OHAINEM SADHEERF REME
HA A SAR AHA
OW
ISTE